hey youtubers is Charlie Game of Thrones
reveals a whole bunch of stuff as a
South by Southwest panel for season
seven season 8 so this is going to be a
breakdown if you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get everything
there's going to be a whole bunch of
Game of Thrones stuff dropping in the
next couple months including footage
behind the scenes stuff in stuff for the
upcoming seasons - so this South by
Southwest panel was a showrunners panel
it was mostly Dan and Dave answering
questions asked by amazing and Sophie in
the rest of the crowd so they gave away
so much more information than everybody
expected including the final episode
count which could still change at the
end of the day but I kind of did this is
like a top 20 there was like a whole
bunch of information so there's really
like 20 big pieces of information
starting with the big stuff the
unofficial episode count now is six
episodes for the final season so they
said when they originally started out
they intended to make a 70 hour movie on
television and that wound up being 73 so
you have 10 episodes for the first six
seasons and then 13 between the last two
seasons seven episodes for season seven
and six episodes for the final season so
that could change but the other big
thing is they confirmed that HBO will do
a spin-off that they themselves will not
directly run or write for they're like
yeah we'll work together after Game of
Thrones because Dan and Dave are writing
team but they said we're not going to do
prequel we're not going to do any
sequels whether it's a movie or they
adapt another book for another TV series
so they'll continue to do things on
their own but it's not going to be Game
of Thrones things but they were like
we're really excited to watch the
spin-off that HBO is definitely going to
do but they didn't say what it's going
to be like if it's going to be Robert's
rebellion or if it's going to be
something set in the past we'll circle
back around to that because that's like
a whole other thing that's going on so
they probably won't talk more about the
spin-offs till we get through the final
season HBO doesn't want to like trample
on any of the Game of Thrones stuff
that's happening now so they'll be
spending most of their time promoting
that helping Dan and Dave get the rest
of the episodes out making it as good as
it could possibly be so moving along
they talked a little bit about the
history of the show they said Peter
Dinklage was the first person they went
to when they were casting the show he
was one of the easier people but the
actual easiest person for them to cast
was mark addy is the aged Robert
Baratheon who had just got a little past
his prime the
artist character for them to cast was
Aria for reasons that will become clear
over the final seasons because her
character becomes such a big badass they
level it mazey is done with the
character obviously they're totally in
love with Maisie and Sophie that's why
they had to moderate the panel just
because they liked them so much but they
said because Maisie Williams is such a
huge edge Sheeran fan in a bunch of the
other people on the cast that they
secretly invited him to come on in cameo
during season seven they said as they
filmed it last year so that makes it
sound like you know wherever ed Sheeran
is going to show up during arias
storyline it'll be somewhere in the
Riverlands and it'll be in one of the
earlier episodes so in the grand
tradition of having singers and
musicians come on and guest stars they
had Gary Lightbody from Snow Patrol will
champion from Coldplay Seger Ross from
Mastodon so no idea if Ed Sheeran is
going to be someone playing music in an
episode or if it will be like a hot pie
thing and they'll be like a funny aspect
to it but they brought them on and they
just like totally freak Maisie Williams
out when she saw him on set like holy
crap jumping forward to season eight
because they're almost done filming
season seven they've already started
handing out writing assignments for
season eight they have a hundred and
forty page treatment that they're
turning into different scripts episode
one is going to be written by Dave hill
he's been with the show since season two
but he's been a writer for the past two
seasons episode two is going to be
written by Bryan cogman who obviously
you guys have probably heard about even
if you don't know who he is he's written
a lot of the episodes of the show then
the last four episodes are split between
Dan and Dave's they kind of bright as a
team so they joked a lot about character
deaths somebody asked them about a white
Walker dragon and they were like yeah
maybe
and they weren't dismissive of it at all
it doesn't flat-out mean they're doing
it but I think they would have been more
openly dismissive of the idea if they
had never intended to pursue it so
there's a lot of rumors that one of
Daenerys dragons might die during season
seven or season eight and be turned by
the night king to become his personal
mount regardless of what George are
Martin intends for the story that is a
TV oh my god moment that everybody
around the world would be talking about
so it sounds like they're thinking about
pursuing it if they haven't already they
joked a whole bunch about killing Sansa
Maisie Williams was like that's why you
still have
on here Sophie because Sansa is totally
dead right now
there was this uncomfortable silence in
the room after they said that and then
Dan and Dave were like yeah we fight
over who gets to kill Santa in the final
season that was mostly then just joking
around a little bit but way before the
sophie Turner had revealed that she was
going to start shooting season 8 in
September just meaning that she'd
survive through season 7 so just one of
the few characters in addition to Davos
that said oh yeah we're going to start
filming later this year it'll be great
so just a couple people to cross off the
potential death list a lot of you been
requesting a video about stuff like that
I will do a death predictions video for
season seven sometime in the next couple
weeks but they said the hardest
character for them to kill on the show
was Khal Drogo just because they like
Jason Momoa so much David Benioff joked
that they were playing a slap game in a
bar during season 1 and Jason Momoa
totally broke his hand so do not mess
around with Jason Momoa this might
surprise you they said that the most
expensive death for them to film it
wasn't Oberyn Martell he was actually
Arya killing Meryn Trant at the end of
season 5 I guess it just required a lot
of practical effects which tend to be
very expensive but going down the list
they all said who their favorite death
was Maisy said this Aerys Targaryen
Sophie said watching Oberyn Martell get
squished Dave said Joffrey's death at
the purple wedding and then Dan said
Ramsay Bolton at the end of season six
they had some fun trying to step around
really spoilery questions someone in the
crowd asked them will Jon Snow and
Daenerys meet on screen and of course we
all know that that's going to happen
eventually but they were like maybe
that's too obvious we should probably
avoid that we all expected to happen
they probably already actually filmed
that scene they talked about each of the
four camera units now there's the dragon
unit the wolf unit those are the two
main ones where they film in Europe
there's the white Walker unit which is
like the separate smaller unit and then
when they mentioned the fourth unit that
fills in Canada for some dire wolf
sequences Maisie Williams did her
impression of a Canadian accent because
she was filming with that unit in Canada
recently so I'll let you put two and two
together if they film dire wolf stuff in
Canada and they were just filming with
Maisie Williams in Canada recently so
just wonder who might show up during
that storyline they talked about some of
the favorite pranks as they pulled on
Danah day says that most of the time it
was them pranking the actors but there
was one time that Nikolaj coster-waldau
pranked them like a week before they
were getting ready to film a season he
sent him a picture of himself with a
completely shaved head the pranks that
they pulled on the cast were usually
riding based like they would hand them
script pages for some really crazy scene
and make them freak out making them
think something terrible was going to
happen they made kit harington think
that they were going to burn all of his
hair off in scar his face when the white
Walker attacked junior Morman in the
early seasons they made sophie Turner
think that she was going to have to sing
during season two probably for Joffrey
and this one's pretty funny they gave
Samwell a codpiece for his costume it
was the size of a loaf of bread so I can
only imagine what they're going to try
and do during season eight when they
prank the cast because it will be the
final season for them the last real big
season 70s that they gave was the Tyrian
would have the best one-liner which is
the way it should be
Tyrion is sort of like the proxy
character for George are Martin the one
that he identifies with the most so he
was created to have the most width so
therefore he should have the best
one-liners there was some criticism
about the quality of Tyrians quips
during season six but it sounds like
they're back on point for season seven
but let me know what you guys think
about all this the idea of a white
Walker dragon the idea that the spin-off
is pretty much a done deal in Dan and
Dave will not be involved with it
George R Martin will once HBO decides
the story that it wants to do he'll help
them flesh that out as they find
producers by that who's going to run the
show so there wasn't any new footage
that they showed out but they'll
probably drop another trailer in the
next couple of weeks usually at least
every couple weeks is when they drop a
new teaser so whatever happens I will
totally do a video for it but if there
are any bonus videos that you guys want
me to do based on this new information
just let me know in the comments all say
congratulations to the new giveaway
winner Candice quintanilla I think I'm
pronouncing your last name right please
private message me on the back end of my
channel so it can get your contact
details you win a copy of the enhanced
editions of the book so my next game of
Thrones bonus video will post next
Sunday just leave all your requests in
the comments below
there'll be new Walking Dead whole bunch
of new comic book stuff coming in the
next couple days too while you wait for
that you can click here for that season
7 trailer
you can click here for new guardians of
the galaxy footage thank you so much for
watching let's high-five I'll see you
guys in the next video